talking about like impact and we we come
in here like i don't know if you've
listened to pockets board but like we'll
have some wild takes and then we try to
justify it
and
one of the wildest takes that might be
justifiable is
you started
streetwear yeah yeah i believe that oh
wow i believe that nowhere
just back here just hear that remember
this is yeah there's a feeling so fast
on this podcast now
how did tony hawk start streetwear we're
talking about streetwear this is like
hip-hop inspired clothing that
everybody's wearing right now now mark
get to how tony hawk skateboarder from
san diego yeah
54 years old am i supposed to i'm 53 am
i supposed to defend this position
you're gonna defend it and you're gonna
dispute it yeah yeah he's already on
board he's like
whatever you want to say
okay so but he had a good argument okay
so go so i played the games growing up
and i loved them and i always noticed
that on all the games there was like the
soundtrack was instrumental so to back
up a little bit streetwear in my opinion
is basically the merging of hip-hop
culture and skateboarding so you have
like brands like supreme and stuff that
you know palace things like that that
skateboarding hip-hop come together so
basically once black dude starts
skateboarding streetwear is born and in
my opinion i think most black kids
started skateboarding because of the
video game now mark grew up with no
black people in his life yeah i know one
so he's great
now you have that one friend yeah
exactly
imaginary
uh that but al could probably confirm
yes that that is true now i grew up in
the city skateboarding right i had a
[ __ ] division skateboard that just
had the little baby lip on the front i
didn't think you're that old
37 i'm out here so but and i remember i
remember it becoming popular and i
remember the video game
and i remember my friends like dominican
puerto rican black dudes were all
playing this game right it was also
popular when like a snowboard video
games were coming out as well and that
was going but i remember an interesting
thing happening because
later on in life i would play fifa the
soccer game yeah and i knew nothing
about soccer and i had friends of mine
that were black were like bro this was
us with skateboarding like i only knew
these guys from the video game i didn't
know them as actual athletes until after
i started playing it okay right so these
worlds collide
this fashion that becomes the
predominant fashion for people now i
guess maybe under 30
right everybody is going crazy because
of you
oh well you need a cut uh
you need a kind of time
i'm okay i'm doing okay
um
i i think got more that
when i
when i was working on a game i set out
to bring the skate culture with that
and that involved
the
skaters the tricks the look the music
the culture and so
i was really proud of how it was
represented in the game i really thought
that the game was only going to be
popular among skaters yeah i thought it
was going to be like i inspired
some skaters to buy playstations
and to me that was it that was the mark
of success because it's because then
that they that means they appreciated it
for being authentic right and what i
didn't what i didn't anticipate was that
it was going to resonate far
beyond skateboarding and to gamers
um and so i wanted i definitely wanted
to be
inclusive i think there's
you know part of me regrets not being
more inclusive with with the roster of
skaters
but because you know we only had we had
one person calling they had one female
skater in but but a lot of people point
to that there was a there was a female
scare in it yeah the steamer i didn't
know that yeah in the first one the
first one yeah wow um
and i also just had you and everybody
who'd been like yeah yeah play the game
all the time yeah i didn't know there
was anyone else yeah we just used you
yeah
the general layout of skating
was more white
um and so but but i'm thankful that if
that's what inspired people to start
doing it especially
in uh different cultures then that that
was awesome like that that's exactly
what i would have hoped for but i just
didn't imagine
that dude it was crazy it was like i was
reading some statistic where like they
thought that it was gonna sell a quarter
million games
and it sold
five million
i have a funny story about that actually
as as the uh
as the game was getting released
they could sense the buzz of it i was
just going a million miles an hour
because i was still doing x games and i
was yeah i was just like
like i was working on the game i know i
was proud of it but i just didn't
imagine it was going to be big
and
they called me right before the release
and they said um we want to offer you a
buy out of future royalties
these pieces of [ __ ] oh my god did the
red flag go off right there do you
realize no are you kidding me i'd like
they said we want to buy you off for
half a million dollars yeah
at that time in my life yeah someone
saying a half a million dollars sounded
like a gazillion billion
and uh
and i had just i just moved into a new
house
um i like i was getting pretty good
royalties still i was starting to make
good money just from being a pro skater
right and i told him i go you know what
i think i'm just going to take a chance
go for it if i hadn't bought that house
right then i probably would have taken
wow
but i had just like i said bought a new
house and was able to pay the mortgage
which is something that uh was new to me
being able to afford the mortgage on my
house
um and so i took a chance and it was
definitely the best financial decision
in my life so were you i mean i don't
want to you know get in your pockets too
much here but like i do want to
but so did they give you like a piece of
the game or like how does it work with
uh yeah royalties yeah so you just get a
percentage of every game
that comes with the game etc
uh if they sell merch or they sell yes
yeah a lot of a lot of stuff happened
um
based on the success of the game i got
all kinds of different
endorsements and licensing deals and i i
definitely attribute that to
success
the thing that that was the
real
silver lining to all of it was that all
of the skaters had a deal that if it
reaches these certain marks of sales
they get a piece they get more money
they get almost what they signed up for
and
that original crew of skaters did really
well that's great